[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn wir euch nach Schweden fragen
würden würden viele von euch sicher
automatisch an Umwelt den Kampf gegen
die globale Erwärmung oder sogar an den
Tierschutz denken schließlich reden wir
über ein Land in dem er als 10% der
Bevölkerung vegan oder vegetarisch lebt
und Diana natürlich ist es auch geräter
thunbergs Heimatland viele von euch
denken vielleicht das Schweden so etwas
wie eine Bastion gegen
Umweltverschmutzung schmutzige Industrie
die Ausbeutung natürliche Ressourcen und
die Ablehnung des kapitalistischen
Lebens per se ist das Land der Kampagnen
für eine andere und bessere Welt die den
Materialismus und die weniger schön
Auswüchse der Menschheit hinter sich
lässt nun ja zumindest denken dass viele
Menschen für andere wiederum ist
Schweden wahrscheinlich ein Land der
radikalen Sozialdemokratie dass die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung mit linker
Politik ausbremst andere denken
vielleicht auch noch an die verfehlte
Einwanderungspolitik und die dadurch
außer Kontrolle geratene
Gewaltkriminalität
[Musik]
aber egal welche Einstellung man diesen
Themen gegenüber hat Schweden ist auf
jeden Fall ein Land das fast niemanden
kalt oder gleichgültig lässt zumindest
fast niemanden aber abgesehen von seiner
Politik hat dieses Land auch noch andere
sehr vielfältige Facetten wusstet ihr
zum Beispiel dass Schweden eines der
genialsten Rentensysteme hat das den
übrigen in Europa meilenweit überlegen
ist falls nicht habe ich euch ein visual
economic Video darüber verlinkt dass ihr
euch unbedingt ansehen solltet ihr
werdet erstaunt sein Schweden ist aber
nicht nur rentengerechtigkeit spitze was
würdet ihr zum Beispiel sagen wenn ich
euch verraten würde das Schweden auch
eine der großen Bergbau Nationen Europas
ist ja richtig nicht nur sein Nachbarn
norwegen ist ein großer Global Player
was natürliche Ressourcen angeht auch
das Land ist knäckebrots und der
Blau-Gelben selbstbaumöbelhäuser ist
beim Rohstoffabbau ganz vorne dabei und
auch wenn das nicht gerade die
umweltfreundlichste Sache der Welt ist
so ist es doch zu 100% war okay nachdem
wir das gesagt haben stellt sich
natürlich die Frage warum um alles in
der Welt Geld reden die Jungs von
visualpolitik über Bergbau in Schweden
ist das wirklich so wichtig nun ja die
Wahrheit ist dass es durchaus von großer
Bedeutung ist der Bergbau dort ist viel
wichtiger als man zunächst denken würde
sieht es euch an 12 Januar 2022 Schweden
findet Europas größtes Vorkommen an
selten erdmetallen das wichtiger als Öl
und Gas werden könnte da habt ihr es
also wir sprechen hier von einem
gigantischen Vorkommen von etwa einer
Millionen Tonnen selten das zu denen
Finnland Griechenland und Spanien
entdeckten vorkommen hinzukommen
es sind 17 Mineral Elemente mit
einzigartigen magnetischen leuchtenden
und elektrochemischen Eigenschaften die
als seltene Erden bezeichnet werden dazu
gehören landhan und Neodym die unter
anderem in der Automobilindustrie
verwendet werden des Weiteren wäre der
Triumph für die Herstellung von
Halbleitern und einigen Arzneimittel
unerlässlich ist und natürlich noch
viele andere mehr
aber vielleicht werdet ihr euch fragen
warum sprechen wir speziell über
Schweden wenn es in einigen anderen
Ländern ebenfalls Vorkommen dieser
Mineralien gibt nun zunächst einmal weil
dieses neu entdeckte Vorkommen an
seltenen Erden das größte in Europa ist
aber es ist auch aus anderen Gründen ein
äußerst interessantes Thema Gründe die
nicht unbedingt etwas mit Bergbau zu tun
haben aber ohne euch jetzt noch mehr
Spoiler zu verraten seid ihr bereit dann
lasst uns gleich nach einem kleinen
werbe Hinweis unseres Sponsors nordpass
loslegen die Nutzung eines Passwort
Managers ist mittlerweile nämlich für
jedermann sich hat von entscheidender
Bedeutung geworden um eine Online Konten
vor verschiedenen riesigen und
Bedrohungen zu schützen zu diesen
Risiken zählen Identität Diebstahl
finanzieller Verlust persönliche
Informationen hochschädigung oder sogar
Erpressung ein Passwort Manager wie
nordpass hilft deine Passwörter sicher
und effizient zu verwalten indem er
starke einzigartige Passwörter für jedes
seiner Kunden generiert und sie
verschlüsselt speichert mit nordpass
musst du dir nur noch ein einziges
Master Passwort merken oder auch einfach
die biometrische Identifikation nutzen
und sicher sein dass deine online
Identität geschützt ist dadurch kannst
du vor allem die Unsitte ein Passwort
mehrfach zu nutzen denn wenn dieses dann
irgendwo geknackt oder geliebt wird
verliert man auf den Überblick was
dadurch alles gefährdet sein könnte
nordpass geht jedoch noch einen Schritt
weiter und schützt deine Daten nicht nur
passiv sondern proaktiv in dem ist das
Internet kontinuierlich nach deinen
Daten abscannen und herausfindet ob
diese nicht möglicherweise gelegt wurden
und falls dies der Fall sein sollte dann
ist es nicht so dass Du rechtzeitig
reagieren und die Gefahr bannen kannst
bevor schlimmeres Unglück hereinbricht
darüber hinaus sind die in nordpass
abgelegten Passwörter und Kreditkarten
auf allen deinen Endgeräten verfügbar
ganz einfach per autofill so dass du
nicht nur sicherer fährst sondern auch
noch viel Zeit Spaß und das Beste für
die visualpolitik Community hat nordpass
eine ganz besondere Aktionen petto bei
Abschluss eines zweijahres bekommst du
einen Monat gratis dazu klicke hierzu
einfach auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung natürlich kannst du
alles in Ruhe unverbindlich und völlig
ohne Risiko ausprobieren der nordpass
kommt mit einer 30-tägigen Geld zurück
Garantie also nichts los besorgt ihr
nordpass und greift damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanziell unter die
Arme das kannst du übrigens auch direkt
mit Hilfe eines spenden links den ich
dir ebenfalls in die Beschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dann bei den damit helfen
wir uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun schnallt Euch gut an wir gehen auf
eine explorationsreise in den hohen
Norden
die Wiedergeburt der bergbaugroßmarkt
der Bergbau in Schweden ist nicht gerade
eine neue Aktivität wir sprechen über
einen Sektor mit einer langen Tradition
der sich über 6000 Jahre hinweg
entwickelt hat eine der berühmtesten
Minen überhaupt die falunnine die heute
nicht mehr in Betrieb ist lieferte fast
ein Jahrtausend dank riesige Mengen an
Kupfer und zwar seit dem 10 jahrhundert
bis 1992 tatsächlich hatte Schweden
viele Jahrhunderte lang praktisch eine
weltweites Monopol auf Kupfer auch
seltene Erden sind in Schweden nicht
völlig fremd immerhin wurden mehrere
diese Elemente erstmals in Schweden
entdeckt ethereum und wurden sogar alle
nach demselben Bergwerk der Grube etabi
benannt wenn wir also über Schweden und
den Bergbau sprechen ist das keine große
Überraschung die Beziehungen zwischen
dem Land und diesem Sektor sind seit
jeher sehr eng das hat dazu geführt das
schwedische Unternehmen einige der
fortschrittlichsten und saubersten
Technologien der Welt entwickelt haben
so verursachte Eisenerz Abbau in
Schweden nur ein Drittel bis ein Viertel
der negativen Umweltauswirkungen die er
in anderen weniger entwickelten Ländern
hat
tatsächlich sind in Schweden derzeit
zwölf große Bergwerke in Betrieb vor
allem in der nördlichen Hälfte des
Landes alle von ihnen dienende Gewinnung
von metallenge sprechen hier vor allem
von Eisen bleibt Zink Gold Silber und
Kupfer Schweden ist seit dem 18
Jahrhundert der Hauptlieferant von
Eisenerz in Europa und produziert
derzeit mehr als ein 90% des gesamten in
der Europäischen Union produzierten
Eisen ein Drittel des Gleis und Zinks
und ein Zehntel des Goldes Silbers und
Kupfers
ja und trotz dieser Fakten könnte das
dem vorgefassten Bild widersprechen dass
viele Menschen von Schweden haben und
auch mit der Tatsache dass dieser Sektor
derzeit mit am stärksten in Visier von
Umweltgruppen steht und natürlich
diejenigen Fraktion der Linken die die
proletarische Revolution und den
Klassenkampf gegen den Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel also den Klima Kampf
eingetauscht haben die Wahrheit ist dass
die Schweden den Bergbau in ihrem Land
so ernst nehmen dass sie sogar eine
ganze Stadt umziehen lassen damit eine
ihrer größten Minen weiter betrieben
werden kann
schwedische Bergbau statt versinkt im
Boden und wird Gebäude für Gebäude
umgesiedelt die Rede ist von kerona
jenem Ort an dem das große Vorkommen
entdeckt wurde dass er am Anfang des
Videos erwähnt haben
doch abgesehen von dieser Anekdote
könnte der schwedische Bergbau
angesichts des Wandels des
produktionsmodells der Energiewende und
der neuen Mobilität die von den
Regierungen weltweit gefördert werden
tatsächlich vor einem neuen goldenen
Zeitalter stehen und vergesst nicht das
ist hier nicht nur um die erbinden
Seltenen Erden geht in den letzten
Jahren wurden auch große Vorkommen viele
andere Ressourcen entdeckt die für die
Zukunft von absolut strategischer
Bedeutung sind vor allem wenn das Ziel
von 0 Kohlenstoffemissionen bis 2050
erreicht werden soll ihr wollt ein
Beispiel nun seht euch mal das hier an
25 Januar 2022 United Listing entdeckt
bei laufend Bohrungen zwei neue Lithium
reiche pegmatitis im bergbau-projekt in
Schweden mit der entjunge entdeckten
Lagerstätte für selten Erden und dem
Lithium vorkommenden Berg Biel könnte
Schweden zu einem der Stadt täglich
wichtigsten Länder in ganz Europa werden
für diejenigen unter euch die sich mit
dem Thema nicht so gut auskennen diese
Rohstoffe Seltene Erden und Lithium sind
für die Herstellung von Dingen wie
Elektroautos Windturbine in einer
Vielzahl von elektrischen Geräten
unerlässlich und zwar so sehr dass
einige Experten sie auf lange Sicht für
wichtige halten als Gas oder Öl für die
Herstellung einer 3 Megawatt Windturbine
werden 335 Tonnen Stahl 4,7 Tonnen
Kupfer
1.200 Tonnen Beton 3 Tonnen Aluminium 2
Tonnen Seltene Erden sowie Zink benötigt
was die Menge an Rohstoffen verdeutlicht
die wir für den Grünen Wandel benötigen
marsch-chef Vizepräsident der
Europäischen Kommission für Inter
institutionelle Beziehungen wie ihr seht
wissen wir jetzt das Schweden ein Land
ist das sehr reich an praktisch allen
diesen Ressourcen ist es ist Europas 400
Produzent von Eisen dem Haupt Rohstoffe
die Stahlproduktion es ist ein wichtiger
Produzent von Kupfer und Zink und könnte
jetzt auch ein wichtiger Produzent von
selten Erden und Lithium werden mit
anderen Worten der schwedische
Untergrund enthält fast alle Rohstoffe
die für die technologische Entwicklung
und die Energiewende unerlässlich sind
aber es ist nicht nur eine Frage der
Wirtschaft es ist auch eine Frage der
Sicherheit es geht nicht nur darum dass
Schweden nur ein weiterer Produzent sein
könnte der nach Angaben der Europäischen
Kommission selbst stammt derzeit rund
98% der seltenen die die Europäische
Union verbraucht aus einem einzigen Land
hat ihr welches 3 2 1 genau die
sogenannte Volksrepublik China
[Musik]
aber wir haben das bereits in einem
früheren Video hier auf visualpolitik
behandelt ich werde es Euch natürlich
verlinken und wenn etwas in letzter Zeit
klar geworden ist dann dass es fatale
Folgen haben kann wenn man sich bei der
Versorgung bei einem wichtigen Rohstoff
zu sehr auf ein einziges Land verlässt
das geht umso mehr wenn es sich bei
diesem Land um eine Diktatur und eine
Regime handelt das dem besten zunehmend
feindlich gesetzt ist so wie es bei oder
sogenannten Kommunistischen Partei
Chinas der Fall ist das Ganze ist also
wahrlich alles andere als ein Scherz
Schweden könnte eine sichere Alternative
sein um diese enorme Abhängigkeit zu
verringern und zu verhindern dass Europa
so etwas passiert
22 September 2010 inmitten von
Spannungen blockiert China wichtige
Exporte nach Japan chinesische
Zollbeamter stoppen Lieferungen von
sogenannten Seltenen Erden nach Japan
und verhindern dass sie ihn chinesischen
Häfen an Gott von Schiffen geladen
werden
29 mai 2019 China ist bereit Seltene
Erden einzusetzen um in einem
Handelskrieg mit den USA zurück
zuschlagen über die Bedrohung die ich
von der Monopolisierung Seltene Erden
durch China ausgeht haben wir schon
mehreren eigenen Videos berichtet ich
werde sie euch verlinken eines ist also
vollkommen klar es ist besser sich nicht
ausschließlich auf chinesische
Lieferungen zu verlassen auch wenn China
über etwa die Hälfte aller weltweit
nachgewiesen Reserven ein selten verfügt
denn das macht die Sache tatsächlich zu
einem großen Problem
der Haken ist dass nach den eigenen
Schätzungen der Europäischen Union der
Bedarf an seltenen Erden bis 2030
weltweit um das Fünffache steigen wird
Elektroautos Smartphones Tablets
Technologien Netzwerke Windturbine die
Nachfrage verspricht phänomenal zu
werden und wir reden hier über einen
Zeitraum von weniger als 7 Jahren wenn
wir also nicht wollen dass sie schwimmen
bringen die U-Bahn behält brauchen wir
dringend Alternativen und hier kommt
eben Schweden ins Spiel neben ein paar
anderen wie z.B Finland ja sogar die
Bürokraten in Brüssel scheinen sich
langsam Gedanken über dieses Thema zu
machen oh will Ziele für
Selbstversorgung mit Rohstoffen
einführen in ihrem Gesetz über kritische
Rohstoffe wird die Kommission über die
klassischen Seltenen Erden und skandium
hinausblicken und sich auf andere
Metalle konzentrieren die für den Grünen
Wandel benötigt werden es ist klar das
Kupfer für die Elektrifizierung der
Weltwirtschaft notwendig sein wird ist
es im Moment eine Priorität die
Regulierung zu erhöhen nein ich denke es
ist eine Priorität erfolgreiche Projekte
zu haben die das liefern was man
dringend braucht auf jeden Fall deutet
alles darauf hin dass Schweden in den
nächsten Jahren eine Bergbauer
Renaissance erleben wird und das könnte
eine verdammt gute Nachricht für Europa
sein doch damit das möglich wird müssen
wir natürlich die einzelnen Punkte
miteinander verbinden bis jetzt haben
wir nämlich nur zwei Seiten die
verfügbaren Ressourcen und die
Bergbauunternehmen die sie abbauen
wollen aber uns fehlt die dritte Seite
und hier gibt es gute Nachrichten
stockholm ist mit im Boot
in den vergangenen Jahren war die
sozialdemokratische Regierung Schwedens
nicht besonders freundlich gegenüber der
Bergbaubranche eingestellt die
bürokratischen Prozesse zogen sich in
die Länge und die erkundungs- und
ausbeutungslizenzen verzögerten sich
ändern laut dem internationalen Ranking
des kanadischen Instituts geschrieben
zwischen 2016 und 2021 also nur
innerhalb von fünf Jahren und Platz 8
auf Platz 6 und 30 der attraktivsten
Länder für Investitionen abgerutscht
doch wie viele von euch wissen gab es im
Oktober 2022 einen politischen
Farbwechsel in diesem Land und der neue
schwedische Ministerpräsident der
konservative Ulf Christa sondern hat
sich zu diesem Thema klar geäußert seine
Position nun er will das Schweden wieder
eine Rohstoff macht wird die neue
Regierung scheint es den
Bergbauunternehmen jetzt viel leichter
machen zu wollen diese können nun
wirklich gesprochen wahrlich zu Hacke
und Schaufel greifen und sich an die
Arbeit machen die Regierung will sogar
die Investitionen des staatlichen
Unternehmens LKA B ankurbeln dass der
größte eisenerzproduzent in ganz Europa
zufrieden sprechen hat die neue
Regierung natürlich noch ein weiteres
Ärmel im Ast das einige Augenbrauen in
die Höhe stellen lassen wird sie wollen
nichts Geringeres als Schweden wieder zu
einer Art Atommacht in der
Energieproduktion zu machen tja viele
Fans von Greta Thunberg werden da wohl
wieder ein paar Panikattacken bekommen
obwohl sich die von ihnen Angebetete
durchaus positiv zur Kernkraft geäußert
hat
Greta Deutschland macht Fehler indem es
die Atomkraft für Kohle aufgibt die
klimaaktivistin Greta Thunberg sagt am
Dienstag im deutschen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen dass
sie es für einen Fehler hatte bestehende
Atomkraftwerke abzuschalten und
stattdessen auf Kohle zur Stromerzeugung
zu setzen sie räumte ein wie sensibel
die Frage unter klimaaktivisten ist und
nannte das Thema eine sehr infizierte
Debatte leider vermochte auch Greta
nicht diese Infektion zu heilen und ja
sie musste aufgrund des gruppendrucks
ihrer Anhänger wieder zurückrudern aber
die schwedische Regierung wird dies auf
keinen Fall tun sehen wir uns daher die
schwedischen Pläne zu Atomkraft mal
etwas genauer an
[Musik]
Schweden 3.0
Schweden eines der grünsten Länder
schlechthin könnte eine der größten
europäischen Atommächte werden wir
sprechen natürlich über zivile Atomkraft
soweit wir wissen hat man in Stockholm
noch nicht über Atomwaffen nachgedacht
aber Energie aus Atomkernen wird
definitiv als einer der Schlüssel für
die Zukunft des Landes in Betracht
gezogen ja genau die Schweden meinen es
damit verdammt ernst der wichtigste
Vorschlag der neuen Regierung besteht
darin das Konzept der 100-prozentig
erneuerbaren Energien durch 100 %
fossilfreie Energien zu ersetzen das
bedeutet dass die Atomkraft in die
Gleichung der Nachhaltigkeit aufgenommen
werden und wenn man nur einen Moment
darüber nachdenkt ergibt das allen Sinn
der Welt
[Musik]
Schweden setzt auf sma's kleine modulare
Reaktoren zu diesen Zweck sind sie
bereits die aktuelle Gesetzgebung zu
ändern und öffentliche Kreditgarantien
zu gewähren wie bisher nur für
erneuerbare Energien zur Verfügung
standen und nicht nur das sie wollen
sogar per Gesetz verbieten dass eine
künftige Regierung versucht die
Stilllegung von Atomreaktoren
willkürlich zu beschleunigen mit anderen
Worten sie wollen Investitionen in diese
Art von Energieerzeugung schützen
tatsächlich wurde all dies in einer
Vereinbarung festgehalten der
Vereinbarung es handelt sich um eine
Vereinbarung die die Regierungsbildung
ermöglichte und die zwischen den
Parteien des rechten Blogs getroffen
wurde im Christdemokraten den Liberalen
der moderaten Partei und den Schweden
Demokraten
so sieht's aus ein politisches
tierparteienabkommen dass die Atomkraft
unterstützt und vergesst nicht dass wir
hier über Schweden sprechen das ist
schon eine ziemliche Kehrtwende dieses
Abkommen enthält auch die Verpflichtung
die notwendige Gesetzgebung zu
entwickeln um kleine modulare Reaktoren
im Land einzuführen Reaktoren die als
die Zukunft der zivilen Atomenergie
gelten
[Musik]
dazu gehört die Aufhebung der
Beschränkung auf maximal 10 gleichzeitig
betriebene Kernreaktoren im Land die
Erlaubnis zum Bau neuer Anlagen an
anderen Standorten als in bestehenden
und die Vereinfachung des
Genehmigungsverfahrens um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben was das
bedeutet während Schweden derzeit sechs
Reaktoren unterhält die etwa 31% seines
Energiebedarfs liefern könnte der Anteil
der Kernenergie anschließend künftigen
Energiemix fast 50% betragen
das heißt dass die Kernkraft in den
skandinavischen Land die gesamte
Grundlagen könnte während die
erneuerbaren Energien die nicht so
regelmäßig Strom liefern den Spitzen
Bedarf decken soll
derzeit haben bereits zwei Unternehmen
eine Absichtserklärung unterzeichnet um
den Einsatz des zukünftigen japanischen
modulreaktors bwrx300 von General
Electric Hitachi zu planen dieser würde
Schweden auf die Spitze der neuen
Energieinfrastruktur Europas heben
sma's könnten sowohl die Industrie als
auch die Kommunen mit planbarem und
fossil freien Strom Wärme und
Wasserstoff versorgen zusammen mit der
neuen Wind Energie wird die neue
Kernenergie ein entscheidendes Teil des
Puzzles für den Klimawandel sein ihr
seht also die Schweden wollen wieder
ganz vorne mitspielen die große Frage
oder besser gesagt die zwei großen
Fragen sind werden sie es wirklich
schaffen und wird man es ihnen erlauben
was wir im Moment mit Sicherheit wissen
ist dass die Studie zum Bau kleiner
modulare Reaktoren in Schweden bis Ende
2023 oder Anfang 2024 abgeschlossen sein
wird und deswegen werden wir alles was
in diesen skandinavischen Land passiert
genau im Auge behalten vergesst also
bitte nicht das Abo unbedingt mit
Glöckchen um auch auf dem Laufenden zu
bleiben und in der Zwischenzeit richten
sich unsere Fragen erst einmal an euch
wird es Schweden gelingen dank seiner
Bergbauindustrie das führende Land der
Europäischen Energiewende zu werden wird
es in der Lage sein seine ehrgeizigen
Nuklearpläne langfristig zu
verwirklichen und die werden die anderen
Länder Europas darauf reagieren wird
sich Deutschland vielleicht von Schweden
auch mal inspirieren lassen wie immer
sind wir auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht auch was dabei gelernt
habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like
und teilt es mit euren Freunden und ist
auch mit Ihnen zu diskutieren vergesst
bitte auch nicht das unverbindliche
Angebot unseres heutigen Sponsors
nordpass der sowieso altpolitik
Community eine ganz besondere Aktion
bietet du bekommst einen Monat
kostenlose Nutzung wenn du den Link in
der Beschreibung unter diesem Video
benutzt natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns hat dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]